딱히 특별한 게 없어 보여도
늘 언제 어디서나 인기 많은 사람의 특징이 뭔지 아시나요?
이번 5분 레벨업에서는
두 건의 참고서를 바탕으로
부담스럽지 않게 은근히 센스 있는 사람의 특징
두 가지를 알려드릴게요
1. 요청 뒤에 숨은 욕구
외모가 뛰어난 게 아닌데도
그렇다고 돈이 많은 것도 아닌데도
늘 인기 많은 사람들의 공통점이 뭔지 아시나요?
바로
너무 많이 준비한 거 아니야?
에이 우리한텐 시우가 있잖아
그리고 나도 있잖아
네가 뭔데?
물론 시우형 같은 쌉존잘도 인기 많지만
원래 나 같은 7의 남자가 진짜 인기 많은 법이거든
0.7의 남자 같은데
에이 뭔 소리야 내가 진짜 보여줄게
와 근데 진짜 잘생기셨다
갑자기요?
진짜로 잘생기셨어요
알아요
와 알아요 이러네
타인의 호감을 얻는 데엔
외모만큼 확실한 건 없습니다
하지만
저 저기요
네
필요한 거 있으세요?
저희 혹시 물티슈 좀 주실 수 있을까요?
물티슈요?
저희 물티슈는 따로 없는데
저 혹시 물티슈가 필요하신 이유가 뭔지 여쭤봐도 될까요?
아 저 그게
양념이 좀 튀어서요
아 그러면
외모만큼이나 타인의 호감을 얻는 데에
정말 강력한 무기는 바로
이거 쓰세요
손수건을 들고 다녀요?
행주입니다
이거 새 거라서 깨끗해요
센스입니다
그리고 센스 있는 사람들의
공통점 중 하나가
바로
대응력이죠
인생을 살다 보면
타인에게 무언갈 요청받을 때가 있습니다
예를 들어
손님이 물티슈를 요청했을 때
물티슈가 준비되어 있다면
그냥 가져다 주면 됩니다
하지만 물티슈가 없다면
즉 상대가 원하는 것을 그대로 들어주기 힘든 상황이라면
대부분은 물티슈가 없다며
거기서 대화를 끝냅니다
하지만 진짜 센스 있는 사람들은
상대의 요청 그 자체만을 보는 것이 아니라
왜 그런 요청을 받는 걸까요?
왜 그런 요청을 했는지
즉 무엇을 해결하고 싶은지를 먼저 파악합니다
그래서 그 요청을 그대로 들어주기 어렵더라도
다른 방법으로 상대의 욕구를 충격시켜주는 방향으로
문제를 해결하죠
뭐야 앞치마 있었어요?
미리 준비해뒀어야 했는데
행주는 다시 가져갈게요
두 번째
피크앤드 법칙
인간관계에서 유독 매력적인 사람들이
정말 잘 맞추는 것이 뭔지 아시나요?
바로 타이밍인데요
그리고 특히
타이밍 중에서도
우리도 이제 가자
저 저기요
네 필요한 거 있으세요?
혹시 끝나고 뭐 하세요?
네?
저 혹시 괜찮으시면
끝나고 저희랑 같이 한잔 하실래요?
오 0.7의 남자 좀 치는데?
오 제 친구가 저분이랑 넷이 같이
한잔하고 싶다고 해서요
에?
에이 그럼 그렇지
저기요 여기 혹시 앞치마 있을까요?
아니요 없는데요
아 어쩐지 아까부터
계속 저 쳐다보시는 것 같긴 했어요
아 개소리하지 마세요
알아요
지금 일부러 차갑게 구는 거죠?
방어기제 같은 건가?
와씨 미친놈이신가?
그만 마셔요
괜히 챙겨주고 싶어지니까
죄송한데
쥐랄하지 마세요
그러지 말고
저희 다 같이 짠 한번 할까요?
오 그럴까요?
어? 뭐지?
다들 어디 갔어요?
뭐야 너 취했구나?
얘네 아까 피곤하다고 먼저 갔잖아
어? 뭐지? 다들 어디 갔어요?
아 그랬나?
인간관계에서 정말 센스있고 매력적인 사람들이
기가 막히게 잘 맞추는 타이밍은 바로
우리 한 병만 더 마실까?
한 병 더?
이미 많이 마시지 않았어?
아니 너무 아쉽잖아
우리 한 병만 더 마시자
바로 헤어질 타이밍입니다
괜히 아쉬운 마음에
조금만 더 한 잔만 더 라며
질질 끄는 분들이 은근히 많습니다
하지만
분위기가 즐겁다고 해서
그 자리를 길게 이어가는 것이
꼭 필요합니다
꼭 좋은 것만은 아닙니다
왜냐하면
피크앤드 법칙
사람은 어떤 경험을 기억할 때
끝부분의 인상
다시 말해
헤어지기 직전의 분위기를
가장 강력하게 기억하기 때문입니다
실제로 미국의 심리학자
대니얼 카노먼은
한 가지 흥미로운 실험을 진행했는데요
이 연구팀은 참가자들에게
고통스러울 정도로 차가운 냉수에
두 차례 손을 담그게 했습니다
첫 번째는 60초 동안 그대로 담그게 했고
두 번째는 60초를 버틴 뒤
30초를 더 연장하되
물의 온도를 아주 조금 올렸습니다
그런 다음 둘 중 어느 쪽에
손을 담그겠냐고
다시 한 번 물었습니다
합리적으로 보면
고통이 짧게 끝나는
첫 번째를 고를 것 같지만
대부분의 사람들은
돌에 손을 담갔던
두 번째를 선택했습니다
왜냐하면
두 번째의 마지막 순간이
조금 덜
불편하게 끝났기 때문입니다
이처럼 인간은
경험의 마지막 순간을
가장 강력하게 기억하는
경향이 있기 때문에
어?
괜히 아쉽다고
질질 끌기보다는
오히려 뭔가 좀 부족하다고 느껴질 때
그래서 살짝 아쉬움이 남을 때
오늘은 그만 일어날까?
어 그래 그러자
다음을 기약할 줄 알 필요도 있겠죠?
보다 눈에 잘 안 띄네
내가 너무 오바했나?
어 약간?
솔직히 너무 신경 쓰이지 않아?
아니 전혀 신경 안 쓰이는데?
에이 뻥치고 있네
그럼 이 옷은 왜 빌려주는 건데?
그거야 신경 쓰는 너가 신경 쓰이니까 그런 거지
...
응?
그럼 나 먼저 가볼게
어 그래 조심히 들어가
응 알았어
너 너도 조심히 들어가
연락하고
응 연락할게
5분 안에 레벨업
비치키를 구독하시고
실전 자기계발 버프를 받아가세요